[Music]
good afternoon my name is David Monroe
I'm a product manager at Google cloud
and I get to work on Sto so first of all
hope everyone had a good lunch there's
nothing like having the first session
after lunch because everyone's got like
you know nice amount of food and they're
starting to get into that night's nice
coma so let's see if we can wake you up
with some nice yeah more during the
course of the the demos and stuff anyway
so we're actually here to talk about sto
we're going to talk a little bit about
also API management on sto so a couple
of you know a couple of demos as well so
but first of all why did Google actually
go around and get you actually
introduced sto as an open source project
so let's talk a little bit about that
the need for a for actual service mash
so everyone knows micro service is
awesome if you think about you know
traditional applications monoliths you
actually have all your business logic in
in one chunk of code you you pick one
language you write your code it you know
to a certain extent you know if your
applications small and your team small
it's actually easier you have one thing
to deploy you have one piece of code
that's doing many things but at the end
of the day again it's just one piece of
code from a where where are monoliths
become more problematic is if you need
to scale certain capabilities within
that codebase independently it becomes
challenging I everyone's working on the
same code base so if you want to change
one thing you're still pushing the whole
application so micro services so the
benefits around micro services are your
developers can actually focus on a
specific set of business logic you can
pick a language that is more applicable
or for that particular business logic so
for example you might use Ruby to write
the front end you might use on a c++ to
write the back end or go so it gives you
a lot of flexibility it also means you
can scale those micro-services
independently of each other you can also
deploy them in a penalty of each other
the only thing and as the developer of
the front end I actually don't need to
know anything about the you know ETL
pipeline I already need to understand is
what interfaces or what API is I need to
connect to and what I need to do to make
that happen so it actually becomes you
know a very you know there's some
definite advantages here but what
happens when you start to really scale
micro-services you deploy in multiple
regions you actually you know you you
have a very large number of micro
services you go from maybe five ten a
hundred maybe to a thousand
micro-services at that point it becomes
very difficult to actually understand
exactly which microservice is talking to
which other Microsoft's it's hard to
understand you know if a specific in
order for you you've only got to have
one micro servers fail and your
application effectively is down so it's
sometimes hard to determine exactly how
you know which micro service is causing
the problem or what's going on within
that environment another thing that's
interesting too is if you're writing
these micro services in different
languages each implementation of a given
protocol might be slightly different
you've got different developers writing
it as a result of that actually having
the same implementation across the
environment can sometimes be difficult
and hard to maintain
so maybe micro services answer cool
after all there's some challenges there
right as that organization as that
application scales you've really got to
start working on how to control that
environment so what do we do in this
type of industry when there's a problem
like this we develop tools effectively
so welcome to a server smash what is
this do
so sto is an open-source project
originally kicked off by Google and IBM
there's a it's actually developing a
huge amount of traction there's a lot of
interest in sto has anyone actually in
this room just a show of hands obviously
you know based on the amount of times
sto has been mentioned in google google
next I'm pretty sure everyone's heard of
it who's actually used it okay excellent
it's quite a few fantastic any sto is
actually a fairly broad framework it
provides a lot of capabilities so let's
talk a little bit about what that
actually you know what what what we can
actually do with this to you so it's
effectively an open service platform
that allows you to manage the service
interaction so I think you basically
start thinking about services first
within your environment the other key
thing here is that actually works across
both containerized environments as well
as VM based workloads so you know and it
could be tential beyond Prem as well as
on cloud or multi cloud there's three
main tenants that sto provides from a
value prop perspective the first tenet
is related to providing uniform
observability with this Co you can
effectively get a common set of metrics
that are automatically implemented
across your environment without actually
having to do that from a developer
perspective the developer now can just
focus on you effectively get this from
the infrastructure the developer can
focus on the business logic you get
operational agility the ability to
change based on a level seven context
how you want traffic to be traversed
through that mesh and what you actually
want to do with that you can also start
providing a policy driven security
posture provide actually your service
service security as well as you know and
this effectively is infrastructure that
the infrastructure can provide you your
software developers now don't have to
worry about providing implementing these
type of capabilities
let's take a little bit of a closer look
history architectural components this is
a pretty you know I think pretty much
every SEO presentation I've seen tends
to have this diagram or something
similar to it there are three major
control plane components there's a part
of each do pilot which we'll talk about
which effectively controls your your
your routing and your forwarding policy
mixer which is actually something that's
pretty interesting
it provides a an extensible model and
we'll talk about some of the things you
can do with mixer and then you got
Citadel which is provides your a lot of
your security aspects of this do so
let's quickly get through this what can
you actually do with security you steai
security because it was actually a
really good talk yesterday I don't know
if any of you got to catch it but let's
talk about security and debt you know
security is not just a perimeter problem
you know one of the one of the drawbacks
or one of the things you need to be
aware of with when you go to micro
services is now you've actually opened
all these channels of communication
between services in between our parts
your application you need to be able to
lock them down so we can use MPLS for
that we also have the ability and we do
that effectively based on service
identity and channel attributes so it's
more than actually just providing MPLS
we can also control the level of access
so service a can talk to service be at
full access service a service C can talk
to service B that may be read-only
access so you can do things like that as
well
if you think about why you support em
tell us this actually gives the ability
via a CEO to basically do a policy
driven encryption in transit but that's
not all the other key thing is around
strong authentication actually
authenticating based on a strong service
identity this is important so I can
actually make sure that if I have a
compromised service that I can't replay
that identity to a different service
let's talk a little bit about mixer so
mixer actually provides really good
extensibility I can effectively use
mixer to interconnect to any back-end I
want to I can use mixer as a way to
actually pull in policy into my mesh and
we'll talk about that and we'll talk
about that specifically in the context
of API management pilot pilot gives us
the ability to basically push not only
the routing rules but also you know
security policy to the proxies in this
case in this example Envoy proxies this
gives us the ability to do things like I
can do a be testing I can do canary
rollouts again all based on level seven
context so this is this is kind of what
is do some of the things that is do
provide I think one of the key things
here is with a little bit of an app so
we have an app this is actually an app
that was also shown at the keynote this
is a hipster app and this is actually
what it looks like so there's around
1112 microservices some are written in
go some are written in nodejs
some are written in Python but this is
just like a typical little microservices
app so let's have a quick look at this
and let's have a look at what we can do
with this do with this so let's say a
transition to the demo so here we have
the hipster store right this is a
everything that you know I think that
they said on the keynote everything that
hipster requires for a for a good
lifestyle so I'm gonna actually first of
all I get a rabbit operator because I'm
actually to go and do some typing I'm
gonna need some coffee
so I'll get a mug for my coffee and then
you know maybe a little bit of music as
well I'll add that all to my cart
oh that's Wi-Fi demons have got me again
okay okay so here we go let's see if I
gonna view my cart are we good
back up and running nothing like Wi-Fi
headed in a conference environment to do
a demo just when you can't possibly mean
not more nervous anyway so here we go so
we've actually got our hipster store
we've placed our order and we're back up
and running
so let's actually have a look at what
this actually looks like so I have a
single cluster running in kubernetes
it's you know it's just relatively small
cluster on that cluster I have a bunch
of workloads you'll actually see some of
the same workloads that were actually in
that that diagram before we have you
know a lot like the front end the email
service but you'll also see a bunch of
history oh components that are here as
well the other thing that we can do is
if we drill into one here you'll also
notice that okay so for this particular
service I'm actually in a drifting of
the pod for a second you'll also notice
I'm doing this a little bit quickly but
for this particular service we also have
in the same same container or same pod
we actually have a sidecar so this is
effectively a transparent sidecar that's
running co-located with that service
okay so what can we actually do we've
got we've got um our service running our
sidecars are all deployed let's actually
have a look at what we can do from a
metrics perspective so I'm actually
gonna come in here I'm gonna actually I
now have a bunch of standard
sto metrics that now just available to
me I'm actually using stackdriver but
these could be piped into any back-end
that you want whether a lot of people
use prometheus graph on ax is their
standard backend of choice so you can
pick a back-end of choice I can actually
look at those metrics very cleanly and
very simply the other thing that I can
do is now I can actually get relational
information so this is the exact same
application now I'm looking at a top a
topology view of what my services are
connected to so if I look at front-end I
highlight front-end I can now see my
exact dependency the other thing that's
really key about this so if you think
about now know if I've got a really
large application maybe you know ten you
know hundreds of micro services and I'm
not exactly sure what my specific
service is talking to I can actually use
a tool like this now to get access to
that I can also then go okay now I know
exactly based on traffic who's
communicating to who and I can start
using that to lock down my
infrastructure create my access control
policy for easier security based on now
this dependency graph the other thing I
can do is I can actually drill in I can
start seeing metrics for that again very
consistently I haven't had to go through
and implement any of this myself from a
software development perspective I can
also start drilling in and actually have
a look have a look at the traces that
exist within this environment so that's
kind of what I can see from a metrics
perspective now let's actually say you
know Dave Dave's a laser product
management guy and as a result of that I
like doing experiments so let's
so the first thing I'm going to do
actually is I'm going to see something
that says reconnecting which doesn't
make me feel very comfortable
alright here we go alright so we can see
the pods that I've got running I'm
actually going to go through and deploy
someone told me that blue makes people
spend more money so I'm actually often
create a version of the front end that's
blue and I'm going to see that now blues
up and running so let's go back to my
hipster app now as a product management
guy I don't really know too much about
you know sto and how it works and stuff
like that so you'll see here that about
50% of the time I actually get a blue
banner now I actually have a load
generator running in the background to
get metrics so it won't be exactly 50%
but I don't necessarily want to do that
I would actually just roll out a new
front-end and apply it to 50% of the
traffic so now what I want to do is okay
so let's see what how I can actually
limit this down I'm actually going to go
through and create a a new rule so I'm
actually going to create a rule this is
what the rule this is the yeah mall
piece right there is nothing like a
product manager using VI in llamó and so
fortunately for me because I'm actually
I think they term they there's a name
for me at Google it's called AG regular
because I'm you know old and fortunately
they haven't changed the commands in VI
in a long time so
so it actually sorts but anyway so so
we've got our we've got a rule so this
is a rule we've actually got a rule that
basically defines what you know gray and
blue would look like from a from a from
a policy perspective now what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to apply that
the other thing I'm going to do is now
I'm actually going to create that was
interesting okay so let's let's actually
have a look at so I actually have a now
I need to actually app layout apply a
rule to that so I've actually have a
rule here that has basically everything
now routed to just the gray I'm going to
apply that really quickly here so I'm
going to apply that rule once that is
applied
nicely flick across and with a bit of
luck look what we've actually restored
things back to a nice harmonious state
of everything great so now what I'd like
to do is okay now actually wanna control
how much traffic goes to gray and how
much traffic goes to blue so I actually
have now a different version of that
rule that waits now one of the things
that this is actually where you start
the differentiate from say kubernetes
for example fide communities and had a
bunch of different replicas on the back
end I can basically only control the
amount of traffic based on the number of
replicas where this actually gives me
very fine-grained control even though
I've only got effectively to two things
on the back end so now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to take that exact rule
I'm going to apply that so now a bit of
luck and the demo gods are on my side we
should see roughly 1 out of that's two
three it seems to be taking a long time
to load before here we go yay come on
around all the floors we actually
finally go on alright Oh heart rate
above 200 not healthy for a guy my age
alright so so that's that's kind of what
I wanted to show so basically I was just
like a bit of a canary roll out at this
point I'm actually going to introduce
none them to come up he's gonna actually
talk a little bit about API management
so we could actually cross back to the
slides
thank you David alright so I'm going to
talk a bit about how API management fits
with sto all the questions I get asked a
lot is if I'm doing micro services do I
need API management or if I've got sto
managing my services do I still need API
management well let's start with what is
API management right let's take a simple
example
I've got service a and service a is
going to call it service B right
if service a and B are really built by
the same team then no not really you
don't need API management you want some
documentation for service B so it's well
documented so people who wrote service a
know how to
locate where most use cases are not that
simple in a very large enterprise you're
going to have many many teams building
services service a and B are not built
by the same team the team that built
service B wants to share that service
with the rest of the organization with
third parties with partners who knows
what else so enterprises want to have a
service catalog where api's are
published to that catalog and this is
different from at run time catalog that
sto provides a catalog for that sto
providers for on Y and the site cards to
find services this is more of a catalog
for humans for developers to come and
read about that service so in addition
to documentation and a catalog the next
thing that enterprises would want is
some way of governing who has access to
which types of services so once you
onboard a developer or some sort of
developer identity is established you
then want to control which developer or
developers can get access to its
services and as an API provider I want
to know which applications consume my
API is it the branch application or is a
call center application or is it the
mobile app which application is
consuming me the services that I built
who are the developers who are writing
applications that are consuming my
services that's the kind of view I want
to have as an API provider some of those
api's you may even want to productize
and monetize api's are quickly becoming
a channel channel through which
enterprises are able to monetize their
data so when you want to productize and
monetize those api's then again API
management is important so these five
factors help you decide if s service
needs to grow beyond your team needs to
be shared with others needs to
eventually be monetized then API
management is important there's another
aspect there's certain capabilities that
you don't want every single service
provider to build right there certain
cross-cutting concerns you've seen this
in the form of API gateways typically do
the job of rate limiting or quotas they
do the job of caching they do the job of
some transform
mediation here's some activities that
you don't want every single team to
build so you build some sort of a
service that they can all leverage all
these are factors that go into API
management so how do they compare from
our point of view you need a steer to
manage all your services that could be a
database service a caching service your
webpages these are all services right
some of those services become api's when
they are shared across your teams across
the organizations right and at that
point you need API management to manage
those api's so all the API is our
services right some of those services
become api's and you'll need to manage
them so how then do we compare the
capabilities of API management and
service management I'm going to go
through a couple of examples on the face
of it they have very similar
capabilities but when you peel the
layers you'll see that there are some
interesting differences if you take
monitoring as an example service
management focuses from a production
operator's point of view right they're
more interested in Layton sees they're
interested in error codes that's what
they're interested in and to pinpoint
where exactly with services failing or
is behaving in a bad way right but from
an API providers point of view they want
to know who are the top five
applications consuming my service that
sort of a business centric view of who
are my top consumers what will happen if
I make a change to a certain API which
applications are impacted that an API
provider would be interested in even if
you take an example like rate-limiting
right Easter will provide rate limiting
at a service level say thousand TPS
right that's that's how much my service
can handle but what someone in product
management can decide is I want my call
center applications to get higher
priority than say my mobile application
because I have more revenue impact if my
branch services are not working as
opposed to my mobile app that sort of a
decision of prioritizing your request
can be done through API management and
of course there are some capabilities
like monetization that it would be only
be applicable within
API management trail so how then do we
make API management work in an sto
service mesh let's bring you back full
circle to what these to your
architecture looks like this is the SEO
service mesh it's got all these standard
components and you know Citadel or
security is not here but easily it could
have been in this picture you're saying
mixer you're saying pilot and you're
saying this icon and ingress the perfect
point to introduce API management here
is at mixer mixer is a policy advisor to
the on y side carves right it Dells on Y
when to allow or not allow traffic right
that's extremely key when you're
enforcing rules or policies also mixer
is a point that is collecting telemetry
data that you can ship it off to your
API dashboard what you'll see here is an
implementation of that API management in
a service mesh through Apogee Apogee has
extended the mixer architecture to be
aware of Apogee API management rules so
as a developer you can define those
rules centrally in the apogee control
plane of productizing your api is
defining quotas finding entitlements of
who can access your api is also publish
those services to the developer portal
to determine who can see those api is
the documentation for it and so on and
when those services are now in the
portal consumers can come and subscribe
to it and get developer keys to access
that service once you have defined these
rules in the apogee control plane mixer
downloads that information and now that
those apogee rules are now present in
the service mesh the enforcement now
happens at the sidecar level or at the
ingress level depending on how you have
defined it so let's take a look at this
with an example right
we had the hipster app right let's say
the requirements changed it was mostly a
web-based application that had a whole
bunch of micro services backing it and
now we have a new requirement right the
shipping service there also allows me to
track shipments right and I want to
expose this track
API if you will part of the shipping
service externally so it can be invoked
not just through the UI but through a
mobile app through something else right
how would we go ahead and protect this
service so that's what we'll do with the
demo next switch to the computer please
alright there it is
so let's go first and get the ingress IP
so I can go and access this API right
let's go do that that's going to store
the ingress IP let's make sure I have
the IP address here I have my IP address
for the ingress now let's go ahead and
access this API all right so I got my I
got access to my API now that's not a
good thing because I access that API by
providing absolutely no credentials so I
want to go and fix that so let me go
ahead and apply a rule to change that
I'll explain in a second what those
rules are
they're actually three files here that
I'm going to walk you through two of
them you do one-time this is a one-time
setup to make your mesh API management
affair if you will
so the first is a definitions file the
definitions file creates custom resource
definitions that tell the service mesh
what attributes to look for so if you're
doing analytics for example what type of
analytics will I want to be sent to the
API dashboard so I want things like the
request URI the path the type of service
that was accessed there are a whole
bunch of metrics that you want to
collect and the definitions file defines
that metric for analytics similarly if
I'm defining API keys or auth we'll do a
look for these values what values am i
interested in is what you define in the
definitions file this is a one-time
setup that I measure operator does once
you're done with that
the next is the handler
the handler creates a configuration that
allows mixer to communicate securely to
the apogee edge instance so with an
Apogee Edge you'd have a tendancy and so
you've defined that but now you want
some sort of a secure ray for mixer to
contact Apogee so it can get those rules
and the last is when do I apply this
policy I've taken a very simplistic view
here the this last step defines when do
I want this rule applied in this case I
said well anytime there's an inbound
traffic apply these rules you may want
to be more selective here you can say
that well apply this rule only if the
label is API or apply this rule only if
the namespace is API or something like
that you can be more creative with when
you want this rule to be applied all
right so now that I have this rule
applied oh that's not good right let's
try to access that API again
I got a permission denied quite as
expected right because I applied the
rule that says no I want to shut this
down I do not want unauthorized access
to this API so now when I try to access
it
it obviously shut me off right normally
what would happen now is that this
developer would go into a developer
portal and say all right I see they're
tracking API right there I'd like to
request access to this and this
developer gets an API key and would use
that key now to access it in the
interest of time I've gone ahead and
gotten one such API key and now we're
going to try and access the service with
my API key okay so same call but with
the API key except this time I am now
able to access that service so the mixer
was able to verify this API key was able
to check against the entitlements so
first was the API key valid then was
this API key allowed to access the
tracking API and then allow that request
in also what happened behind the scenes
and you'll see this in a few minutes
mixer sent telemetry information about
this API call to the API dashboard
all right now more often than not you
know API keys are not sufficient for
enterprises they'd like to secure it
with a lot all right let's do very
quickly if we can also do off here so
I've applied a spec that's now going to
implement or look for OAuth tokens let's
take a look at what that file looks like
this is the the OAuth spec that I have
for the shipping service what you'll see
here are three pieces of info one is
which service do I want protected
that's the shipping service that's the
target and second what issuer should I
look for in the JWT token and you can
see the URL there that's the issue I'm
interested in and lastly what's the JSON
web key endpoint I can get that's where
the public keys are hosted that's hosted
in Apogee at this point so how do I
verify this token once this policy is
deployed on why will now check if the
token is expired or not and if it is not
exploited the public key is valid right
I mean there's a digital signature be
valid but that's one step that's almost
like the authentication step make sure
that your JSON web token is reasonable
but that's every JSON web token
accessing every API ten what about the
next step can this user access this API
so in others those attributes are passed
a mixer mixer will still apply the
Appaji rules to say all right is this
JSON web token allowed to access the
tracking API and that's what we'll see
next so let's go ahead and get a token
all right so I've got a script here that
will allow me to get a token so let's do
that and store it in a variable let's
look at that JSON web token really long
string I'm going to now parse it and
show you what that looks like so let's
go put that in a file so you'll see what
is in that token and let's try that okay
so you're seeing parts of that JSON web
token there because what is inside that
token is the API key or the client
identifier for that JSON web token this
then allows mixer to check if the JSON
web token is really allowed to access
this particular API because you may have
a rule where you know this client ID can
access a the email service but not the
tracking service so that next step of
entitlement check is also done by mixer
so let's now call the same service using
the access token instead of the API key
I got back my my JSON again so what
we've been able to do is to protect the
API while defining certain rules in the
service mesh well what's also now
interesting to see is if I can get this
dashboard also show up in the API
dashboard because I want analytics for
it so I'm going to refresh this and I
get hourly metrics day week and so on at
the moment I'm just going to pick our I
have a load generator running so you'll
see many more requests than I actually
generated here but I can dial down some
of the sto specific information and
start looking at the shipping API the
response times here and so on but also
more importantly look at some of the
developer aspects of it so who was a
developer who built the shipping service
how many errors does this developer
generate so on and so forth as
information I can get by looking at the
API dashboard alright back to the
presentation please okay so to quickly
summarize
service management is needed for all
your services and when you share those
assets with other teams external vendors
and partners API management is available
for you now David for some announcements
so this is actually being mentioned
before but STO 1.0 is literally right
around the corner in fact I think
there's actually even on sto dot IO
there is a countdown
walk for the the exact time that they
believed exactly right so one lads oh
that's a pretty big deal we also have
managed to see ong ke which is a going
into alpha so if people are interested
in and maybe a way to have a play with
this teo in a GK environment let it let
us know please reach out we're actually
taking people on that side and we also
have some Apogee API integration yes and
that's going to be the g8 the same day
he steers 1.0 so you guys can look up
github it's also open source
[Music]